>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Sam Litzinger: Ken has
been a longtime supporter of
and participant in the
National Book Festival.
I remember interviewing him
at I think it was the 2007 festival
we decided when he was talking
about the war, his
documentary on World War II,
which started conversations
with veterans
in households all over the country.
A reminder that you can support the
festival with a gift of a donation
by checking the information in the
festival program and on the app.
The organizers welcome your help
in making the festival possible
next year and every year.
This amazing gathering would not
be possible without the support
of sponsors and book
lovers like you.
If you would, please turn your
cell phones off, lest I be forced
to quote the late Oliver
Sacks whose sharp response
to a beeping phone while he was
giving a talk, reminded me happily
that CSPAN doesn't
censure rough language.
Some of you may have seen that.
The way we'll precede is that
I'll ask a few of the 10,000
or so questions I have for Ken
and then invite you
to ask some of yours.
There are microphones, I think if
I'm seeing right, in the aisles here
and here and so please line up
at those when the time comes.
Be advised that our gathering is
being recorded for the archives
so if you're a spy or
an international person
of mystery you may
want to remain seated.
Otherwise be brave
and step right up.
I'm really not going to give
Ken a very long introduction,
although he's worthy of
one, because I do think most
of you know his work by now.
Don Hewitt, who created 60 minutes
at CBS was often asked
about his philosophy.
His response was simple,
tell me a story.
Ken Burns is a storyteller.
He's also a historian who
understands that a great way
to tell a story is
to make it personal.
A big important story can be told by
finding the small important stories.
The famous Sullivan
Ballou letter you heard
in the Civil War is
a perfect example.
You can't hear it and not be
moved by it and come to understand
that terrible war in
a very personal way.
Ken has a new book, which is
here on the table behind us,
Grover Clever Again, a
Treasury of American Presidents.
It's beautifully illustrated
by Gerald Kelley.
It's intended for younger readers
but I define older readers not
to take great pleasure in it too.
It's the latest addition to Ken's
wonderful body of work and I ask
that you join me in
welcoming him, Ken Burns.
[applause]
>> Ken Burns: Thank you.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
>> Sam Litzinger: Ken, we're
at the National Book Festival,
do you remember a time
when books became important
in your life for the first time?
I was lucky enough to have a father
who read to me before I could read.
>> Ken Burns: My answer is
that I don't remember a time
when books weren't important
to me because I was read
to from the moment I was
born by both my parents
and it became a huge part of it.
And though my mother was sick I was
able to also spend a lot of time,
very precious time, with my father
who would read me long novels
that would take several
weeks to read,
books that he had gotten as a child.
And so I felt that
they connected me.
I was speaking earlier this
morning and remind people
that often children born in
poverty have a deficit by age 3,
they hear 30 million
fewer words than people
who are not born in poverty.
And we begin to understand
that despite all the other
obvious economic pressures
that we have this lasting deficit
that is going to be very difficult
to make up and I feel so
extraordinarily fortunate
that not only was I read
to but I've also been able
to read to my own kids.
I have four daughters
ranging in many ages
and I think the intimate
connection I have
with them has been
foraged over books.
>> Sam Litzinger: I understand
the family was an influence
in the origins of Grover
Cleveland again.
>> Ken Burns: So you are talking
about a person who makes films
about American history, who
tries to define those stories,
thank you very much for
your generous introduction,
and when it was time for bed, when
the books were finished reading,
when the lights were off and I was
either lying next to my daughters
in bed or in a chair next to them, I
would drill them on the presidents.
So I would say George,
they would say Washington.
I would say John, Adams, Thomas,
Jefferson, James, Madison, James,
Monroe and we would go through
and halfway through you get
to this wonderful anomaly
which always delighted
them as they remembered.
In the beginning I would tell them
stories about each of the presidents
or just say who was next and
some important circumstance.
But when you get to Grover
Cleveland, Benjamin Harrison,
Grover Cleveland again, and each
daughter, one is now turning 35,
when she first memorized it, when
we finished it I said you know what,
Sarah, we should write
a children's book.
That was 30 years ago.
Her sister, four years
younger, Lilly, same thing,
I said we should do
a children's book.
I'm really serious this time.
Olivia, who was 11 six years
ago, committed all the presidents
to memory that way and I said now
it's time actually to do something.
And my youngest, Willow, who's 5,
the same age as my granddaughter
who I haven't yet drilled the
presidents on, she did it.
And if you go to the Random
House Children's Book website
and look this up you
will see Willow Burns,
age 5, reciting the presidents.
Which means anybody can do it.
But the idea was to originally
do kind of an [inaudible],
something that would just
be presidents to memorize.
But as we got into it we realized
that these were all human beings
and somehow that they had
been placed at and removed
from us, put up on pedestals.
They were no longer human beings.
They were the sum total of their
successes or their mistakes.
And these were all people who
had parents, who had siblings
for the most point, who had pets,
who had hobbies, who had kids,
and that it was important
to humanize them.
And so the book became you know
richer and richer and denser
and denser in that so that
like a kind of Grand Canyon
of many layers it's
possible to just use it
to help you memorize the presidents
and know what the number is.
Abraham Lincoln, by the way, is 16.
That it was also possible to learn
a little bit more about them.
And so we have what we call the
baseball card, the information
of when they were born, when they
died, when their administration was,
their brothers, their sisters,
but then a large section
that would be helpful for kids
a little bit older writing book
reports and even older than that
writing more extensive book reports.
And so we think we have, as Random
House calls it, Knopf calls it,
a treasury of the America.
That this is something
that you could hold on to
and last for a long time.
>> Sam Litzinger: Part of
the problem for a historian
or a documentarian or a writer
in general it seems is
knowing what to leave out.
>> Ken Burns: Yes.
>> Sam Litzinger: This book
could have been 1200 pages long.
>> Ken Burns: You know it's pretty
interesting, this took a lot longer
than I thought it would take.
It was a lot harder than
I thought it would be.
I'm used to working on
projects for many, many years.
I have a film on the history of the
Vietnam War that's coming out a year
from now and when it comes
out I will have worked
on it more than 10 years.
So we're used to that.
But I had thought that you could
just scoop in and you can't.
You have to do as much work
for this book as you had to do
for even a biography
of the president.
And we had it vetted by a number
of distinguished historians who do,
are great, great happiness said, I
learned stuff that I didn't know.
And they're folks who have spent
their lives studying the presidency
and writing, you know, big,
huge, thick books about it.
So in order to figure
out what to leave out,
you know I live in New Hampshire.
We make maple syrup there.
And it takes 40 gallons of sap to
make one gallon of maple syrup.
And I'm sure the amount of
material that we collected for each
of these presidents was at least 40
times what we could possibly use.
And then the work was how to tell a
story that didn't make them wrong,
that made them interesting
and humanized them,
but also let you know that there
are some very potent issues going
on in American history about
race, about money, about honesty,
about all sorts of things and
that's part of the book as well.
>> Sam Litzinger: Are you
a merciless self editor?
>> Ken Burns: Yeah, we're
pretty tough on each other.
I should say from the start, I
should have said from the start
that David Blistein, who is my
oldest friend, and Cauley Powell
who works in my office
were both instrumental
in making this book happen and their
names are listed on the title page.
So we would spend a great deal of
time together sifting and digging
and chapping and writing
and rewriting.
But yeah, you want
to get it just right.
>> Sam Litzinger: Do
you love research?
You must at this point.
>> Ken Burns: I love it, love it.
I mean I just had the great pleasure
of meeting the new Librarian
of Congress and you know I think
it's the Librarians of Congress
who should be billionaires.
[laughter] You know and teachers.
[applause] Our values are
little bit upside down.
But you know I've spent my
life in libraries and archives
and museums trying to figure out
how to make the past come alive.
>> Sam Litzinger: Do you
always find a surprise
when you're digging through stuff?
>> Ken Burns: Every, every,
every single project
is a constant surprise.
You know I was working on the
Civil War series and you know
that is the most important event
in American history but as you said
in your introduction, sometimes
the smaller detail is more telling.
If you think about it, the
architecture of the atom is the same
as the architecture
of the solar system.
So that you could find, as
the poet William Blake said,
the world in a grain of sand.
And that's what we try to do, to
make something, to personalize it is
to often go down to
the tale in detail.
So not too far from here is a little
town called Winchester, Virginia.
It changed hands 72 times
during the Civil War.
We don't think of American towns as
changing hands, let alone 72 times,
and that always is the thing that
I go back to to just be reminded
that these little nuggets are
also incredibly instructive.
Humor is also another thing
that is very helpful, you know,
alligators in bathtubs and
working in your dads saloon
as Martin Van Buran
did, these are all stuff
that helps us understand
these complicated people
that we more often abstract and
make the subject of term papers
and not the fact that they
were flesh and blood like us,
that they had to put on their pants
one leg at a time or hopefully
at some point put on
their dresses, you know.
[laughter] [applause] Sam
Litzinger: A reminder,
if you'd like to ask a question you
can in just a couple of minutes.
You might even want to kind of
cue up at the microphones now just
to avoid a frenzied
rush to get up here.
I just have a couple more questions
before I open it up to those of you
who have them from the floor here.
You're best known as
a documentarian.
Do you tend to think
visually when you write?
>> Ken Burns: No, as a matter of
fact, that's a wonderful question
and I never really have
a chance to explain this.
I am drawn to visual things.
But I will go out, say to the
Library of Congress working
on the Civil War, and I will
just film all the photographs
from the Brady collection
that I'm drawn to, visually,
because they tell good stories,
unconcerned with whether
they're going
to illustrate some
part of the script.
And too often films
are made that way.
Let's just look for the
image that's going to get us
through paragraph 2 of
page 7 of episode 6.
And that's a horrible way to do it.
You miss a lot of good
stuff that way.
So I go and try to
film the good stuff.
Meanwhile as the left hand
is doing that the right hand,
unaware of what the left hand
is doing, is writing stories
with writers so that
we are unconcerned
with whether we have visual
material to illustrate it,
we just want to tell that good
story in an literary sense.
And then editing, the most critical
period for us as it is you know
for most of us, is where
the horse trading goes.
And sometimes we find ourselves
with an abundance of image
for which there are no stories
to use but then you find a way
to use them and create new scenes
and sometimes you have a story
that you have to have but there are
no images and you invent new ways
to do it, using some of those
images or some equivalency.
It's incredibly exciting.
It tends to lengthen and attenuate
our process but that's the best way.
And then there's a
kind of durability
and evergreen nature to the stories.
I mean mostly when you say
documentary most people think
of people who are advocating
a particular point of view,
exposing something that's
very relative in that moment.
But quite often history
is addressing all
of the same issues we're addressing
today but it's doing it about events
that took place seemingly before
and unrelated to us but are
so resonant with human nature.
History doesn't repeat itself.
We're not condemned to
repeat what we don't remember
but human nature never changes.
And understanding the patterns
and the themes and the motif
of the past arm you in
the best possible way
to understand the present.
You know Ecclesiastes
said it better than me,
what has been will be again, what
has been done will be done again.
There's nothing new under the sun.
And that means that human
nature super imposes itself
over the random chaos of events
and we can perceive those
patterns and that's what we do.
Mark Twain is supposed to have said
that history doesn't
repeat itself but it rhymes.
[laughter] And it's a wonderful
phrase if in fact he did say it.
But I spent my entire
professional life, 40 years,
trying to hear those rhymes,
trying to hear that stuff.
And so quite often when you take
a subject that seems safely,
distantly in the past it
is resonant with today.
I'll give you a simple example,
our recent film this past spring
on Jackie Robinson, which
was sort of exploding some
of the sentimental myths about him
and telling a much more dynamic
and complicated person, is
speaking to the themes that are
on the front page of today's
paper, about Black Lives Matter,
about driving while black,
about stop and frisk,
about integrated swimming
pools, about integration,
about housing disparities, about
wage disparities, all of the things
that are still omnipresent
in our discussion
about race today are happening
in the context of a story
that we've normally just
relegated to a happy story of a guy
who turned the other cheek.
He did and it's impressive
but the story
of the real Jackie
Robinson is more important.
That's why I think coming
to terms with these guys
in a human dimension allows them
to remain fresh and new to us just
as we deal with many
of the same themes.
George Washington and Thomas
Jefferson were dealing
with the same themes of race
we're dealing with today.
>> Sam Litzinger: At a conversation
we are probably, are we ever going
to finish that conversation?
>> Ken Burns: I don't think so.
I mean and we have to be
pretty honest with ourselves.
This is our original sin, we
know as a country that we,
where we were founded and when,
July 4, 1776 in Philadelphia
and we know what our catechism is,
it's the second sentence
of the declaration.
It begins, we hold these
truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal.
Yet I have to stop right
there, a third of the way
through that wonderful sentence,
arguably the second greatest
sentence in the English language,
the first is obviously I love you,
but after that you'd be hard pressed
to find a better statement,
sentence, because the guy who wrote
that owned more than 100 human
beings and didn't see the hypocrisy,
the contradiction or see fit
in his lifetime to free any
of those human beings and set
in motion American narrative,
symbolically but also literally,
that is constantly
struggling to deal with that.
And as what's going on today, it
happens to be Charlotte or Tulsa
but you know a year and a half ago
it was Charleston, North Charleston
or Ferguson or wherever, it's there.
So we've got to deal with it.
And many of these people, most of
those people, were in some way,
shape or form either having to deal
with it or consciously trying not
to deal with it but then moved as
closer to Civil War or into some
of the problems we suffer today.
So you can get to the heart of who
we are by picking up almost any one
of these mini biographies
and understanding, wow,
as William Faulkner said,
history is not was but is.
>> Sam Litzinger: I have a lot
more questions but you have a lot
of questions too so let's
get to some of those
and then I'll wrap things up
with a final question of my own.
I think you have a book
signing up, I think, at 1:30 so
>> Ken Burns: I do, at 1:30.
>> Sam Litzinger: So for those of
you who would like to have your copy
of Ken's book signed by Ken,
1:30 is the time for that.
Let's start over here.
>> As a middle school
librarian who has to try
and teach students the
art of doing research
and the benefits when it's hard.
I was wondering were you a student
that fought that or did you find
that that was something
that drove you
and that's why you became a writer?
>> Ken Burns: I think
it's hard for everybody
and there's some resistance
to it to not just,
I mean today we have the luxury
but also the deficit of being able
to sort of look it up on
Wikipedia and get something.
>> Information overload.
>> Ken Burns: But it's not just that
but when I first went to my site
at Wikipedia it gave me
three films I'd never made
and took away four that I had.
[laughter] And it took a year
and a half to correct that.
So those of you who are about to
trust that, one of the key hallmarks
of not only research but of
journalism and history is
to triangulate, to get a couple
of different things right.
And I always found, as I got older,
the hunt was actually more exciting
than the final thing because you
discovered stuff you never realized
you were interested in.
I was at the Museum of the
Confederacy in Richmond going
through all the photographs.
We finished.
I said do you have others?
He said only seconds,
do you want to see them?
And I said sure, meaning
duplicate copies.
So he brought out a box, a cardboard
box, filled randomly, not filed away
in acid free paper, and we went
through and I said nope, nope, nope,
a couple times I said
yeah and I filmed them.
At the bottom, tucked under
the flap, I pulled it out
and it was a picture of
Robert E. Lee with this sort
of enigmatic Mona Lisa smile.
And I said I've never seen
this photograph before.
And I heard the greatest
thing I've ever heard
from a librarian archivist
ever which is neither have I.
[laughter] I was like, you
know, it was like striking gold
in the California gold rush so.
>> I need you to call my
superintendent and tell them
that you can't teach students
to be curious in 30 minutes.
[laughter]
>> Ken Burns: Yeah, yes, thank you.
>> Sam Litzinger: Also Ken
did not direct Casablanca,
for those of you who were wondering.
[laughter]
>> Ken Burns: Yeah that's right.
>> Sam Litzinger: We're running out
of time, I'm sorry, to talk so much.
Here we've got, what, about 10
minutes, something like that?
No, even shorter than that, oh,
Ken they're cutting our time.
>> Ken Burns: A lightening round.
>> Ken, first of all,
thank you so much
for the Civil War documentary,
absolute masterpiece.
I'm a huge, huge fan.
But the talk earlier was focused
on how it was a challenge for you
to make the historical
record personal to people.
You're trying to tell a story.
I'm curious about your own personal
experience when you're immersed
in the research and you're
looking at primary source material,
have you ever had a personal
struggle or an emotional kind
of reaction to the material
you've been working with?
>> Ken Burns: Always.
>> And had that immediately?
>> Ken Burns: Always and in
fact every film is a struggle
as it should be.
It ought to obliterate, assassinate,
conventional wisdom
and preconception.
And so you come in, all of
us are burdened by that,
and then all of a sudden when you
dig down it's much more complicated
and therefore challenging
but much more interesting.
And as you say, sometimes
emotionally startling.
>> Thank you.
>> Sam Litzinger: Last question
from me, Desert Island books at sort
of the National Book Festival.
You can have some books to
take to your desert island.
You can also have some documentaries
because you're good at that.
What do you want to take with you?
>> Ken Burns: Oh my
goodness, I don't know.
>> Sam Litzinger: You can
change this in a year.
>> Ken Burns: And can I pack
a lot of books, you know?
>> Sam Litzinger: You
can have a couple.
>> Ken Burns: Abraham Lincoln used
the vinyl Old and New Testament
and the Works of William
Shakespeare,
that was basically his education
until he was reading for the law.
You know these are great stories.
Some are made up, some are
fanciful and sort of allegorical.
But that's the way we intuit them.
So I, you know, I, an American,
all of my subjects are Americans.
I don't think that Mark
Twain wrote a bad sentence.
He said the difference
between the right word
and almost the right
word was the difference
between lightening and
the lightening bug.
But more to the point,
if we're going to go
out on a literary figure,
Mark Twain said,
it's not that the world
is filled with fools,
it's just that lightening
isn't distributed right.
[laughter] That will be
funny in a thousand years
if there's still civilization
to talk about, right?
>> Sam Litzinger: Absolutely.
>> Ken Burns: And think of any
other 19th century humorist,
whatever they said
isn't funny anymore
but that will be funny
a thousand years
from now and everybody gets it.
>> Sam Litzinger: Ken Burns
has to sign some books.
He's got to get there.
Thank you very much.
>> Ken Burns: Thank you very much.
I'm so sorry I couldn't
get to your questions.
>> Sam Litzinger: Thank you.
>> Ken Burns: Thank you.
>> Sam Litzinger: Thank
you very much.
>> Ken Burns: Thank you very much.
[applause]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.